the 2020 pandemic has changed life in
the city pretty dramatically in the
height of citywide lock downs it could
be very eerie to look at it as Street
and see no people and no traffic traffic
and urban centers has been like a
constant but under the threat of
coronavirus many have been experiencing
what life could be like without it a
little after 6:30 and we're looking at
the West LA area what is different in
this picture well how about this it's
probably about 10% of the cars that are
usually out here traffic in the United
States has been a growing problem over
the last decade especially in San
Francisco where each commuter spends 103
hours waiting in traffic every year and
the costs of congestion totaled over
five billion dollars in 2017 and while
it may seem like the natural solution to
pave more roads and increased freeway
space the city is actually taking the
opposite approach like many European
cities it's removing cars from its
downtown and if it works it might just
help spread this idea of building cities
around people not cars now since I live
in Brooklyn and likely I'm not traveling
to San Francisco anytime soon I'm
recruiting the help of my colleague
Laura bliss not only because she lives
in the Bay Area but because she's been
reporting on coffee streets for years
the amount of congestion on the streets
that's grown in recent years is really
striking Texas A&M University has
published a study which says traffic
here in California and especially here
in the Bay Area is bad just since 2010
the number of vehicles entering the city
on a daily basis has grown by 27 percent
this growth has been driven by cheap gas
prices but also the rise of ride
handling apps like uber and lyft and in
San Francisco the tech boom has meant
more people are coming into the city
every day there's also a really sharp
uptick in pedestrian fatalities that the
city has seen in recent years and this
is an issue that all of the United
States has been experiencing over the
last decade so the city has done a
number of things over the years to try
to address its traffic problem and most
recently the city is launching the
better Market Street plan
well another plan is in the works to
transform San Francisco's Market Street
it sure looks great on paper a mega
makeover of San Francisco's mid Market
Street well you will not be seeing cars
all the way back to the dawn of
automobiles Market Street has struggled
with a diverse amount of transportation
needs from pedestrians to cyclists cars
and public transportation and even back
in 1906 it could get a little hairy one
of the most iconic things about Market
Street is that it's really just kind of
a almost a free-for-all it's about 9:00
a.m. just at the end of rush hour and
we're gonna ride all the way down to the
Ferry Building an experienced Market
Street firsthand and all of its problems
you've got goobers you've got private
cars you've got delivery trucks you've
got buses
that's just blocking the way what if you
do it you've also got like a you know
historic streetcar that's just kind of
throttling along and even though Market
Street has dedicated bike lanes when
cars need to turn right off the road
those bike lanes kind of disappear and
cyclists end up kind of weaving in and
out of traffic
at best this can lead to increase
congestion and at worst it can lead to
an accident
the city's better Marcus Street plan
aims to fix us by removing private cars
from entering the road
allowing dedicated lanes for trams buses
and cyclists to run unimpeded for the
two-mile stretch as well as a large
renovation project to the pedestrian
walkway and while construction will take
years to complete the first step
removing cars is already infected ribbon
took well over a decade of debate
environmental review and design planning
they've been talking about limiting cars
on Market Street almost since cars were
invented or at least since bard was
invented by November of 2019 the San
Francisco transportation administrators
voted unanimously to approve a better
Market Street plant generally speaking
these kinds of projects do not go down
without a massive fight one of the most
explosive fights in recent years that's
gotten a lot of attention here in the
United States was the 14th Street Bus
Way plan in New York City it's not going
to be your mother's 14th Street anymore
from third to ninth avenues it will
morph into something city officials call
a TTP it means private cars can pretty
much forget about it
similar to the Market Street project the
14th Street bus away was a plan to
remove private cars from entering the
road the intention here was to improve
bus service but some New Yorkers didn't
like it I am furious
we are furious and generally speaking
people oppose pedestrian zones or car
bans for three main reasons first people
fear that the traffic's who think have
pushed two parallel roads and that those
side streets are just gonna be stuck in
gridlock second there's the fear of the
loss of on street parking and finally
business owners fear that that loss of
parking could mean the reduction of
customers and revenue to their business
a plan to ban cars on one of the busiest
cross streets in Manhattan hits a
roadblock Arthur Schwartz represents the
group that's suing the city is a
thousand cars an hour on this
on streets that is not a good trade-off
for anybody if anybody in the right mind
thinks that there's not going to be a
major impact because of this they're
crazy but once the carbon went into
effect the data came back in was pretty
clear there was no side street traffic
coppola track traffic cop ellipse people
love to get biblical with traffic you
know that karma get in and this is
Trevor Reid transportation analysts at n
Rex and yes he's also working from home
do you play football football and I'm
back at home with my parents so I did
play football your childhood stuff yep
yep pretty much in Rix worked with a
third-party consulting firm Sam Schwartz
consulting to collect data around how
the traffic changed after the 14th
Street bus way the end result of the
14th Street bus way was an absolute
success on all the parallel streets
you're seeing a travel increase in
travel times by about one to two minutes
which is negligible that you're seeing a
36 percent improvement in bus speeds
which was I'd point three minutes faster
on average which correspond to a twenty
four percent increase in bus riders so
over 6,000 increased riders and you saw
a spike in bicycle volumes of you know
between 26 and 50% but Market Street is
a little different
unlike 14th Street that's laid out in a
fairly traditional grid with streets
running parallel Market Street only has
one side of parallel street options
mission that runs north and south and
Howard that only runs southbound and
while it may feel like all that
displaced traffic for market is gonna
have a bigger effect on streets like
Mission the results were almost the same
in the morning on Mission Street
northbound you know we're seeing a
change in the range of 30 seconds and
then in the afternoon an increase of
about a minute in the a.m. on Mission
Street southbound it was a negligible
change you're talking about 10 seconds
or so at the 9:00 a.m. period increasing
to about a 50 second increase in travel
times at 10:00 in the morning and your
afternoon period change was
again about 10 to 15 seconds during the
peak period and an overall Howard Street
was really showing no statistical change
and while there is a small uptick in
traffic delay
Trevor points out that that's not
looking at the whole picture it's not
just displacement of vehicles when you
put in these bus ways they also absorb a
lot of those vehicles as new riders it's
not fate but you're gonna have 10,000
cars going to a point every you know
every day it changes and people adapt to
change it only took one day for bike
rider ship to jump 20 percent after a
month that number jumped to 25 percent
bus speeds are running six percent
faster on average up and down Market
Street and some lines have actually seen
a 12 percent improvement you know when
you're measuring your benefit and
thousands of people and negative impact
in you know a dozen cars it's it's
really uh you know it's a no-brainer as
far as the benefit versus cost and as
for how loss of parking is gonna affect
the local business vendors think that a
much higher proportion of their
customers are coming via vehicle than
they are it's 240 square feet to park
their personal vehicle and the odds are
is that's one one customer know
restaurant or convene or store can
survive in an urban context just based
upon people driving parking and going to
use that service there's actually been
proven a positive economic correlation a
lot of these in a lot of lis contexts
following the improvement of bus or bike
infrastructure because you're actually
getting more people and into an area
than you were previously with with the
on street parking because of the shelter
in place order has been difficult to
create any concrete economic data around
the Market Street project but around the
world evidence has been pretty
strikingly positive it used to look like
this a parking lot with 75 cars parked
here so the City Council proposed to
take away like 60
fifteen left and then the merchants here
said no we want them all gone because we
are right off the pedestrianised stone
where sales are better after central
Madrid went car free with a pretty large
swath of its downtown area and now no
access to cars it's seen nearly a 10
percent boost to retail sales for
businesses in that pedestrian zone and
it's also seen greenhouse gases dropped
by 32 percent but not all car free
street projects are looked at as
successes in the u.s. during the 60s and
70s cities created what were known as
pedestrian malls streets were congested
parking was inadequate and pedestrians
were endangered the solution separate
cars and pedestrians for the benefit of
both in short what was an ordinary
typical Main Street is now an
extraordinary place designed for the
enjoyment of people it was an attempt to
help failing downtown areas attract
customers as shopping had moved to more
car friendly shopping centers in the
suburbs and while some of these malls
are still thriving today failures and
cities like Chicago have left a lasting
to space for such projects pedestrian
zones car free schemes are definitely
not silver bullet solutions that are
just gonna magically fix an entire
city's traffic problems overnight even
the most successful ones still come with
their considerations a big one is that
people who rely on cars because they
have disabilities sometimes say they
feel left out of the planning processes
around making hole corridors car-free
because you still need to ensure that
there is easy to use accessible pick-up
and drop-off zones for those folks
especially when public transit is not
incredibly easy to use
another issue is that community leaders
sometimes point out that car free zones
are usually created in thriving
commercial corridors but some planners
say that that can exacerbate existing
socio-economic gaps especially since
low-income people of color in the United
States are disproportionately victimized
by car crashes and very rarely do you
find these car free zones in their
communities it's one of many structural
inequalities built into cities that
marginalized communities and their
allies say must be overcome everyone's
learning from each other and you see
what success looks like and you know
it's and it helps that a lot of these
interventions are very affordable you
know paint is cheap you know you created
a subway line worth of capacity on 14th
Street with some paint and a little bit
of enforcement in that that cost-benefit
is just unbelievable and since traffic
isn't as large a concern for cities
during the corona virus pandemic
some are actually closing off roads too
cars entirely there are a number of
cities that are intentionally limiting
or blocking access to vehicles on
neighborhood streets as a way to boost
access to outdoor space and create safer
corridors for essential workers by foot
or bike Oakland California was one of
the earliest cities to adopt this model
Oakland SLO streets is trying to send a
message that we want
Oakland ders to recreate in a socially
distanced manner and it's a question out
there right now whether some of those
car free streets could be made permanent
some city is including Seattle have
announced that they're going to keep
theirs in place indefinitely and Oakland
officials have suggested that they would
like to but related concerns have come
up including in Oakland at the
implementation of these projects
happened too quickly and without very
much input at all from neighbors
including low-income communities of
color who fear they could be
disproportionately policed in these
spaces
another question on urban planners Minds
right now is whether there's going to be
a surge in demand for driving private
vehicles and therefore a surge in
traffic even though very few cases
around the world have been linked to
riding buses or trains there's this
general concern about overcrowding and
the transmission of coronavirus
that could push people away from transit
or even living in dense areas where car
free streets make sense these are huge
questions on city planners Minds right
now as the coronavirus transforms the
world around us the streets are no
exception
[Music]